I just didn't write his first book even
thinking he was going to publish it I
think I'm just writing it for myself
he's like we could actually use it with
the companies it'll be like a manual
that's exactly what it was yeah one day
he woke up in the morning and if I'm
gonna publish it maybe I'd do it in like
a few months
I kept telling him I was like well it is
fantastic like it's going to blow up
like you don't need to do anything and
then one day you woke up and you were
like I put it on I put it on Instagram
you know he made one post no marketing
it just literally went viral off Word of
Mouth how much time he puts into writing
when he gets into writing mode where
it's like weeks on weeks of like right
I'm like hello are you hungry you go in
your closet just to turn off the light
and it's because he genuinely loves
writing like books are special to me
because like I've learned a lot from you
know reading if you think about like
when people die the only thing that has
like stayed for two thousand five
thousand years is like written word and
so I think there's something magical
about that and spend a lot of time
trying to make it really really good
that was the goal for the book and you
know when I told Layla that I was like
why would I promote it because people
aren't telling their friends that it's
good then why would I want anyone else
to read